key mapping is a technique that game
developers use to allow players to
customize their experience in playing
the game so for instance if they don't
like moving around using WASD they can
shift over their controls to use the
arrow keys instead now looking at the
grits controls we can see a number of
different potential input methods that
we need to keep track of for example we
can move around with WASD but we allow
two different variations for how to
shoot so at some point in the future we
may have a need to change how our keys
are laid out this means that somewhere
in our code we need to have the ability
to variably modify what key corresponds
to what action